italy is about to become the first
european country to mandate covet 19
health passes for all workers in future
employees will need to have a so-called
green pass or be suspended from their
jobs without pay they also have the
option to show a negative test but they
will have to pay for this the government
says it hopes the measure will help to
increase the take-up of vaccinations
italy's government taking tough measures
to combat covert 19. from next month it
will be mandatory for all workers in
public and private sectors to get a
health pass users will have to show
proof of vaccination a negative test or
recovery from infection
the green pass is an instrument of
freedom that makes places safer secondly
the green pass makes our vaccination
campaign more effective
on the streets of rome there's a mixed
reaction to the announcement
in such a serious situation we need
effective solutions
in my opinion it's not fair because i am
a free citizen i can decide whether or
not to get a green pass when there's an
obligation we no longer live in a
democracy but a dictatorship so i don't
agree
italy is the first country in europe to
implement the covert 19 green pass for
all workers originally it was set up to
ease travel restrictions and give access
to indoor venues authorities now say
expanding the measures will help the
vaccination uptake stop infections and
prevent further lockdowns those who
ignore the decree could face fines up to
1 000 euros but persuading everyone to
get inoculated may be challenging the
country has seen protests in recent
weeks including at various railway
stations
italy was one of the worst hit by the
coronavirus pandemic last year more than
130 000 people died
while around 74
of the population have received at least
one covert 19 shot it's a delicate
balancing act for authorities now to
prevent a repeat of the past as winter
approaches
journalist sima gupta spoke to us
earlier from rome about what the italian
government is hoping to achieve
let's not forget italy has lost more
than a hundred and thirty thousand lives
due to kovit 19. now that's the highest
figure in the european union uh that's
it though those uh people that are
against this you have a group that are
the anti-vaxxers and we've seen them
become more and more vocal in recent
weeks uh they've been participating in
protests uh many have been accused of
carrying out death threats onto
politicians or being even violent
towards journalists they feel simply
strongly against the idea of vaccines on
the other side of the coin though you
have those that are simply afraid
to take the vaccine they don't want uh
to do it they don't trust it they're
concerned about their safety and so
really that's the government's task
right now you've got a month before this
kick kicks in a month for companies to
get their uh procedures together in
order to check these uh
green passes and also a month they're
hoping to convince those who have still
not been vaccinated to go ahead and get
that vaccine done or otherwise be sure
to be tested regularly and to produce
that negative test before you can come
into work